donc je pense qu'il va y avoir un
vent de victoire indéniable
soufflant dans les voiles des djihadistes
du monde entier car ils disent que la
victoire est possible, ce n'est pas une
lutte sans espoir,
continuez le combat, restez fidèle à vos convictions
et 20 ans plus tard, vous  peut finir par
gagner cette guerre et je pense que le
récit les fera avancer pendant un
certain temps dans le futur, je pense qu'il
reste à voir euh dans
quelle mesure euh l'afghanistan redeviendra une base
pour que des groupes terroristes internationaux
lancent des attaques à l'extérieur de euh  je
pense certainement qu'al-qaïda en sera
rajeuni et se
renforcera je pense qu'une grande partie de euh l'
effondrement rapide de l'asf était
dû à leur euh à cause du leadership euh
il n'est pas clair que les dirigeants étaient tous
debout et combattaient leur  terrain, je
pense aux soldats sur le terrain, la
perte d'alliés qui fournissent
des facilitateurs et un soutien importants euh est
également euh aurait affaibli leur
détermination et leur désir de continuer à f  tout en
sachant que les américains partaient
et que donc ils prendraient
cela seuls et qu'ils seraient très
exposés je pense que nous n'allons pas voir
des attaques immédiates émanant de l'
afghanistan vers l'ouest
parce que les talibans auront appris
du  20 dernières années que laisser cela
se produire sur votre territoire conduit à
des résultats difficiles assez négatifs et
dangereux, donc je pense que de leur
point de vue, ils essaieront de limiter
ces choses, mais c'est une question
de savoir jusqu'où ils iront pour imposer
cela à  divers groupes qui sont forcés à leurs
côtés pendant un certain temps en
afghanistan sur le champ de bataille et qui
veulent finalement lancer des attaques ou essayer
de renverser d'autres gouvernements ailleurs,
je pense clairement qu'ils seront renforcés par
les stocks importants d'armes dsf
qu'ils collecteront euh  et puis je pense
qu'il y a un autre matériel haut de gamme
qui sera intéressant de voir comment
il est utilisé
euh les drones en particulier il y a beaucoup
de chauve-souris  drones tlefield que les américains
ont donné aux forces afghanes euh et
nous en avons déjà vu un certain nombre tomber
en afghanistan certains d'entre eux je soupçonne que
les talibans utiliseront euh d'autres qu'ils pourraient
essayer de vendre ou de remettre à des alliés
ou à d'autres pays autour  afghanistan
qui ne sont pas des alliés américains comme la chine
ou la russie ou l'iran
[Musique]